Du jasmin,
des herbes sauvages,
de l'oranger.
J'adorerais créer mon parfum,
un parfum Épicurieux.
Pour tous ceux qui aiment transmettre,
pour tous ceux qui aiment apprendre,
mais aussi pour tous les autres.
Le savoir a enfin son parfum.
Érudit by Épicurieux,
Sympa, non ?
Bon, c'est un peu compliqué
mais je vais quand même
vous donner la recette.
Sur le podium des cadeaux
les plus offerts pour la fête des mères,
le parfum arrive sur la deuxième marche,
derrière les fleurs
mais avant une invitation au resto.
Et, ce n'est pas la seule occasion
pour laquelle on achète un parfum.
En France,
il se vend en moyenne plus de 150 000 flacons de parfum par jour,
ça fait plus d'un par seconde.
La plupart des parfums de grandes marques sont fabriqués sur la Côte d'Azur,
à Grasse.
Dans cette petite ville de l'arrière
pays niçois,
on crée et on fabrique aussi
toutes sortes de senteurs
qui embaument notre quotidien.
Et, on fabrique des parfums pour tout :
pour la litière du chat, l'eau du fer à repasser, l'odeur des viennoiseries.
On reproduit même
l'odeur du gazon fraîchement coupé.
Pour fabriquer un parfum,
on commence d'abord par capturer
les odeurs produites par les fleurs
et on ne les attrape pas au vol.
Ces substances se concentrent bien souvent
dans les pétales,
c'est le cas pour les roses.
Elles se présentent
sous la forme de molécules très volatiles.
Au passage, une molécule,
c'est une combinaison d'atomes,
des grains de matière.
Du carbone, de l'hydrogène, de l'oxygène, tout ça, c'est de la matière,
invisible évidemment.
Pour fabriquer un parfum,
il faut donc extraire ces molécules,
un peu comme on extrait
du fer de la roche.
Alors, il existe plusieurs méthodes
pour y parvenir,
l'une des plus répandues est l'extraction par solvant.
C'est un processus complexe qui, en temps normal, prend beaucoup de temps
du coup, j'ai un peu simplifié.
Vous n'avez pas que ça à faire.
Première étape : cueillir des fleurs
et détacher les pétales.
Ça, c'est à la portée de tout le monde.
Maintenant, un peu de chimie.
On dépose les pétales dans une cuve.
Bon, la mienne est un peu petite,
dans la réalité, on traite jusqu'à
100 kilogrammes de pétales de roses.
Deuxième étape : on verse de l'hexane.
Il s'agit d'un solvant,
les molécules odorantes
vont s'y dissoudre.
En fait, l'hexane a une très grande
affinité avec les molécules odorantes,
les deux se lient facilement.
Ensuite,
il faut récupérer les molécules odorantes,
pour cela, on chauffe.
Sous l'effet de la chaleur, l'hexane s'évapore et à l'arrivée,
il ne reste plus qu'une sorte de matière
visqueuse.
On dirait un peu de la cire
ou du savon noir,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la concrète.
Hmmm, ça sent déjà très bon.
Normal, car la concrète contient
toutes les molécules odorantes
qui étaient présentes dans les pétales.
Bon, il y a aussi pas mal de corps gras.
Du coup, le travail n'est pas terminé,
il faut maintenant laver la concrète.
Pour la débarrasser des corps gras et des impuretés,
on utilise de l'alcool
et une fois l'alcool évaporé,
on obtient, ce que l'on appelle, l'absolut.
Vous en avez déjà entendu parler, non ?
C'est un liquide parfumé, ultra concentré.
Un peu fort quand même.
Les rendements de cette substance
sont très faibles.
Pour produire un kilogramme
d'absolut de rose, par exemple,
il faut 800 kilogrammes de fleurs.
Ça vaut une fortune,
un kilogramme d'absolut
à partir de roses cultivées à Grasse peut coûter plus de 10 000€.
Pas étonnant
qu'il soit réservé aux marques de luxe.
C'est à partir de ce produit
que les fameux nez qui travaillent
pour les grands parfumeurs composent
leurs assemblages et créent des parfums.
Le nez est au parfum
ce qu'un œnologue est au vin.
Il doit assembler différentes fragrances
comme un œnologue assemble
différents cépages ou millésimes.
On ne compte pas plus de 500 nez dans
le monde, dont une centaine en France.
Pour composer un parfum,
ils ont à leur disposition des extraits
de plantes, de fleurs, de fruits, de bois,
de racines, de graines, de feuilles.
La palette olfactive
de la parfumerie est immense
et ils peuvent combiner jusqu'à
une trentaine d'odeurs.
Et maintenant,
comment fonctionne notre odorat ?
Pourquoi certaines odeurs nous plaisent et d'autres, non ?
Avez-vous déjà senti
l'odeur du gaz dans votre cuisine ?
Ce n'est pas très agréable.
Eh bien, c'est fait exprès.
Cette odeur soufrée a été ajoutée au gaz
qui, lui, n'a pas d'odeur.
Le but, c'est de détecter au plus vite
les fuites car les mauvaises odeurs
nous interpellent autant que les bonnes.
Le mécanisme de détection est le même.
Les molécules odorantes pénètrent dans la cavité nasale,
puis au fond de cette cavité,
elles se fixent
sur des récepteurs spécifiques.
Chez l'humain, il y a environ
5 millions de récepteurs olfactifs.
En comparaison,
les chiens en ont 220 millions.
Chaque récepteur ne peut détecter
qu'un type de molécules.
Quand une de ces substances
se lie à un récepteur,
elle active le neurone qui le prolonge
et fait remonter l'information
jusqu'au cerveau qui l'interprète
comme une odeur particulière.
En général, les odeurs que nous sentons
autour de nous sont composées
d'une multitude de molécules odorantes
qui activent donc,
de nombreux récepteurs.
Vous imaginez alors le nombre de combinaisons possibles
et donc le nombre d'odeurs
que nous pouvons sentir.
Revenons au gaz,
la combinaison donnée par son odeur
provoque une sensation de dégoût.
Ses effluves soufrées
ne sont pas agréables,
on dirait de l'œuf pourri.
Dans notre cerveau, cette odeur de soufre
est rangée parmi les mauvaises.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien, parce que c'est l'odeur
que dégage un aliment en décomposition
et un aliment qui dégage
une telle odeur, s'il était ingéré,
pourrait provoquer une intoxication.
Avec le temps,
notre cerveau a associé cette odeur
à d'autres dangers,
au risque d'explosion ou d'asphyxie.
Au contraire,
les effluves d'un gâteau au chocolat
qui sort du four peuvent vite
nous mettre l'eau à la bouche.
Elles activent
le circuit de la récompense,
elles provoquent
la libération de dopamine,
une molécule associée au plaisir
et surtout à l'envie de croquer dedans.
Mais tout le monde n'a pas la même
définition de ce qu'est une bonne odeur.
Prenons l'exemple du camembert,
son odeur est appréciée
d'un grand nombre de français.
Personnellement, j'adore.
Mais pour beaucoup d'étrangers,
cette odeur est répugnante.
L'apprentissage joue donc
un rôle important dans nos perceptions.
On l'a vu avec le soufre,
à force d'expérience, on se met à aimer
ou à détester telle ou telle odeur.
Mais cela peut aussi
être dû à la génétique,
car tout le monde ne dispose pas
des mêmes capteurs.
Tenez, la plupart des français,
par exemple,
sont sensibles à l’androsténone,
une hormone odorante produite par le porc, notamment.
Si la viande de porc en est imprégnée,
ça va les dégoûter.
Mais les personnes qui ne possèdent pas le récepteur sensible à cette hormone
ne seront pas dérangées.
Bref, bonne ou mauvaise,
une odeur, c'est avant tout une question
d'apprentissage, mais aussi de génétique.
Et il n'y a pas que l'odeur
qui peut déranger dans un parfum,
son prix aussi.
Le jus contenu dans le flacon
ne représente pourtant
qu'entre 5 et 10% du prix,
le flacon entre 10 et 15%,
les 80% restants, c'est du marketing
et un peu de distribution.
Alors qu'au départ,
lorsqu'il a été inventé, ce n'est ni
un objet commercial ni un moyen de masquer les odeurs corporelles.
Le parfum servait à communiquer
avec les dieux.
Son histoire débute il y a 4 000 ans.
À cette époque, les Égyptiens se mettent
à brûler des aromates
ou de la résine
pour entrer en relation avec leurs dieux.
En effet, cette fumée qui monte,
évanescente, semble de nature
à atteindre les dieux qui eux aussi
sont impalpables et immatériels.
Cette pratique est à l'origine du mot
parfum.
"per fummum" en latin,
qui signifie par la fumée.
Mais bien vite, son utilisation évolue,
les corps des défunts sont embaumés
avec des aromates,
les statues des divinités sont frottées
avec des huiles sacrées parfumées.
Enfin, les hommes et les femmes
commencent à s'en mettre sur la peau.
Par la suite, les grecs et les romains
l'adoptent à leur tour,
il devient indissociable de la toilette
et s'invite dans les bains publics.
Un terrible événement va propulser
les parfums sur le devant de la scène.
Au XIVᵉ siècle, la peste noire dévaste
l'Europe et la peur de l'eau s'installe.
On cesse alors de se laver, au prétexte
que l'eau
augmenterait les risques d'infection
en ouvrant les pores de la peau,
permettant ainsi aux miasmes
de pénétrer dans les corps.
Du jour au lendemain,
les bains sont proscrits.
Alors,
pour camoufler les mauvaises odeurs
des corps mal lavés, eh bien,
on utilise du parfum.
On en met partout, sur les vêtements,
sur les objets du quotidien,
partout donc, sauf sur la peau.
Plus tard, à Versailles,
on asperge les mouchoirs,
les éventails, les perruques,
mais aussi les boiseries.
On raconte même que Louis XIV faisait
parfumer les fontaines de Versailles.
Heureusement, à partir du XVIIIᵉ siècle,
l'air redevient respirable
car on redécouvre l'hygiène.
Peu à peu,
les parfums se font moins capiteux,
l'heure est alors au raffinement
et ça dure toujours.
J'aime bien celui-ci.
Voilà,
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous conseiller
la lecture de ce bouquin
"Le Parfum" de Patrick Süskind,
l'histoire de Jean-Baptiste Grenouille,
un parfumeur un peu particulier.
À l'origine, le bouquin était sous-titré :
“L'histoire d'un meurtrier”.
Je ne vous en dis pas plus,
vous me direz en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez.
Allez, bonne fin de journée,
excellente semaine et à dimanche
prochain, chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.